and you have the sort of extraordinary
scenes of pro Donald Trump protesters a
few anti-donald Trump people and members
of the American media and the
international media all mingling in
together sharing the same space we did
I'm gonna John Sparks I'm going to
interrupt you apologies
John Sparks I'm going to interrupt your
apologies look he has got out of his
motorcade uh he has entered a cafe let's
just listen to the atmosphere in there
[Applause]
he's a great guy
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
thank you
against us and father we thank you that
you've given us president Trump to stand
against the wave that's coming against
our nation the father is Cuban Americans
we declare communism will not come to
our Shores father we thank you that
you've anointed him and called him for
this time in Jesus name amen
again foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much
Donald Trump wants to be seen remember
that it was our understanding that he
might be heading to a Cuban Cafe uh
presume this is the same one it was
called if it is posing for photographs
and a way of them but remember
and this is a man for whom misses free
publicity for an election campaign that
he sworn he will continue to fight
Donald Trump in this Cuban Cafe gold
Versailles surrounded by supporters this
was organized and swept before
everyone or favorable support
come on
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday
[Music]
I think it's going great I think it's a
rig deal here we have a rigged country
we have a country that's corrupt we have
a country that's got no borders we have
a country that's got nothing but
problems We're a nation in Decline and
then they do this stuff and you see
where the people are we love the people
and you see where they are you see the
crowds and everything else we have a
country that is in Decline like never
before and we can't let it happen I'm
gonna make a little speech tonight in
Bedminster
it's moving
thank you